este 6 de diciembre venezuela celebra
unas cuestionadas elecciones para
renovar el legislativo del país el único
poder en manos de la oposición hasta el
momento está presidido por juan guaidó
lo que le permitió proclamarse como
presidente interino tras las elecciones
presidenciales de 2018 en las que
nicolás maduro obtuvo la victoria en
unos comicios no reconocidos por la
comunidad internacional en medio de
acusaciones de fraude
ahora why do reconocido como mandatario
interino por más de medio centenar de
países
llama al boicot e insta a los ciudadanos
a quedarse en casa en rechazo a los
comicios se ratifica la fecha del fraude
hay un intento por parte de la unión
europea como ustedes lo saben de mediar
para obtener condiciones mínimas en este
proceso y aquí voy a hacer paréntesis
miren lo que sucede mañana no tiene nada
que ver con la legitimidad de ese
proceso ya maduro y el régimen tiene muy
claro que nadie va a reconocer
intimidad a ese proceso por su parte el
presidente nicolás maduro asegura que
las elecciones son transparentes y que
con ellas el país demostrará al mundo
que es el pueblo quien decidirá qué
fuerza política tomará el control de la
asamblea oposición que te vas a la calle
para atacarme a mentir y a decir tanta
bolsería acepto tu reto vamos entonces
domingo un plebiscito si ustedes llegan
yo me voy de la presidencia
la oposición ha convocado a partir de la
próxima semana una consulta virtual con
la que wide o busca demostrar el rechazo
generalizado a los comicios y ampliar su
margen de maniobra ante una eventual
concentración total de poderes en manos
del oficialismo